michael lind is a senior fellow at the
New America Foundation and co-author of
the radical Center the future of
American politics his new book made in
Texas times the rise of George W Bush to
the political ascendancy of the south he
spoke recently in Dallas Texas for about
50 minutes all right like to welcome
everyone to Borders Books and Music here
at Preston Road in Dallas Texas we're
pleased to have mr. michael lind who's a
senior fellow of the new america
foundation and he's the author of the
next american nation up from
conservatism and another book in Vietnam
as well as several volumes of fiction
and poetry including the Alamo the blue
bonnet girl and his co-author with Ted
Halstead of the radical Center the
future of American politics
he lives in Washington DC and also owns
a beautiful ranch near Fredericksburg in
Texas so we're pleased to welcome mr.
michael lind to borders books and music
thank you well thank you uh Ferris rooks
to land borders it's a particular
pleasure for me to be back here buddy
hear me all right
to be back in Dallas I have many family
connections here my great grandfather
Richard Augustus Herron was the first
acting dean of Southern Methodist
University I had my mother grew up here
my distant cousin Larry Hagman portrayed
the Dallas billionaire oilman jr. Ewing
on on Dallas I I regret that the only
Texas oilman in my extended family is a
fictional character and in particular
I'd like to acknowledge the memory of a
Decker Turner who passed away last year
he was the director for many years of
the BRIT whale library at the at
Southern Methodist University in this
book indeed is dedicated to him in
memory of his contributions to the Civil
Rights Campaign during very dark times
in Texas history I'm a fifth generation
native of Texas you have to I have to go
back three generations to find anybody
among my ancestors who wasn't born or
buried in the state and I live in
Washington DC and have been involved
off and on with politics and journalism
for about 15 20 years now in the
misconceptions about Texas that I find
in the rest of the country you know are
one of the reasons why I wrote this book
you know to see European and British
writers explaining the Texan character
in terms of the desolate empty spaces in
which Texans live of course most Texans
live in fairly well watered a green
Texas east of the Balcones Fault and and
I'm always amused to see the popular
image of Texas's as a friend of mine
puts it as this sort of cross between
Montana in Arizona and indeed that's one
of the themes that I start off with in
my book made in Texas I say partly in
the spirit of provoking controversy but
I think there's something to it that
Texas has always been a southern state
masquerading as a western state by that
I mean from the 1850s onwards the
dominant ethnic and religious and
cultural group in Texas consisted of a
what I call anglo-celtic southerners to
include the scots-irish as well as Anglo
Americans there were always other groups
in Texas obviously African Americans
Mexican Americans a considerable number
of German and other immigrants
particularly in Central Texas but
scattered throughout but it was the
anglo-celtic southerner who defined the
image of the Texan and if you look at
this sort of Texan frontier stereotype
it actually migrated westward into Texas
along the Highland South the character
character of the kaintuck and of The
Tennessean followed the many Tennesseans
who had gone to Texas signs when they
moved here in the 1850s well what this
means for Texas politics is that it's
very difficult to distinguish a unique
Texan tradition from that of other
southern states politically Texas was
always the westernmost extension of the
South rather than the easternmost
extension of the West that's not to say
that much of West Texas and the
Panhandle and Central Texas didn't live
up to the reality of cattle drives and
and of Latino Anglo heritage but simply
that the center of gravity politically
of Texas has always been in the most
southern section of Texas and you see
this in the fact that Texas joined the
Confederacy that Texas joined the other
southern states during Reconstruction to
overthrow the reforms that had been
imposed by a federal occupation into to
redeem the state government redemption
of course meant a return to the rule of
the ex-confederate oligarchy in my
chapter the confederate century i go
over what was the dominant political
system in this state from the end of
Reconstruction up until the civil rights
revolution of the 1950s in the 1960s and
it was very similar to that in Alabama
Mississippi other southern states it was
based on in politics of one-party
democratic dominance in economics a kind
of plantation economics which I call
southern aa mcc's where Texas
specialized like many other southern and
western states in supplying raw
materials and commodities to the
industrialized regions of the Northeast
in the Midwest and a particular kind of
Protestant fundamentalism that that is
endemic and unique to the American South
just to illustrate my point about one
party politics in my book I quote Lloyd
Bentsen senior the father of the Texas
senator Lloyd Bentsen who was an
immigrant from the Midwest in the early
20th century Lloyd Bentsen senior
visited RB Krieger the state chairman of
the Republican Party which was a pretty
lonely place in the early 20th century
he said I told mr. Krieger that I wanted
to join the Republican Party since my
daddy had always been a rock red
Republican in South Dakota he said young
man do you want to do what's best for
Texas I said I did and he told me you go
back to mission and join the Democratic
Party because what's best for Texas is
for every state in the Union to have a
two-party system and for Texas to be a
one-party state when you have a
one-party state your men stay in
Congress longer and build up seniority
and and consequently uh for that
strategic reason of divide and rule
Texas and the rest of the South had
one-party democratic rule the real
election in in these years consisted of
the Democratic primary there were
Liberal Democrats and moderate Democrats
and conservative Democrats but that was
the real election because the Democrat
was going to be elected in any event
during this period that I call the
Confederate century this period of white
supremacy and of dominance by the land
owning elites and the one party
Democratic Party
we got a particular to my mine rather
noxious form of Texas politics which was
phony populism there had been real
populist back in the era of William
Jennings Bryan and Tom Watson in the
1880s and 1890s who challenged the
conservative power structure in the
south and they were pretty much wiped
out by reforms which Texas and other
southern states adopted from Mississippi
in the early 1900s certain kinds of
literacy tests poll taxes which
effectively disenfranchised all African
Americans and about half the white
population so that's one way to get rid
of your populist yeah well have luminate
them from the electorate so there was a
kind of hollowed out populist style
where you had these very flamboyant
show.we figure heads backed up by the
business and land owning elite in the
state and one of them of course was
Texas governor and a u.s. senator
W Leo Daniel better known as past the
biscuits Pappy O'Daniel a country music
singer who went on to become governor
and would periodically serenade the
legislature while the lobbyists did
their business I quote a couple of of
his campaign songs my favorite is from a
campaign song in 1940 now used to have a
grouch or even have a frown for
everybody's happy when Pappy comes to
town so when people tell you that Ronald
Reagan was the first show business
candidate at Texas pioneered this
particular kind of of populism and then
sometimes members of the elite govern in
their own right one was Alan shivers who
was particularly adept in the 1950s at
race baiting and at a red-baiting
I quote a memo to governor
shivers written by one of this campaign
managers Wilden heart you badly need a
burning issue for the last ten days such
as segregation furnished in your closing
first primary drive the outside labor
bosses haven't scared the voters much as
too many of them either don't believe
the threat is real or don't see how they
are involved either way I submit for
your consideration a double prong
program to bring the labor issue closer
to home by using the Port Arthur story
this was a labor union ization in Port
Arthur as a threat to businessman
everywhere to using the forum labor
unions ation threat especially in West
Texas and then this early spin doctor
warned governor shippers that quote
because of your personal involvement the
governor might be open to counter-attack
he was referring the fact that shivers
was a rich landowner from the Anglo
dominated Rio Grande Valley of South
Texas where his overseers exploited
non-unionized mexican-american labor so
that was the rather dismal situation in
politics in economics Texas and the
other southern states and many western
states had a rather unique system in
which they fit into the industrial
economy of the United States as a whole
by acting his resource colonies and and
this was a deliberate system this was
not just the result of the natural
environment I mean you can have
factories anywhere in factories in Texas
there was collusion between the local
landowners who were perfectly content to
specialize in cotton in cattle and then
later on in oil and sulfur and mining in
northeastern investors because the
investors the venture capitalists in New
York and in Pittsburg in these other
northern cities would only invest in
commodity enterprises in Texas they were
not interested in investing in small
businesses they were not interested in
investing in manufacturing enterprises
and in fact they colluded with each
other and and the railroads to prevent
manufacturing from growing up in Texas
in the 1880s in the 1890s the the
railroads actually charged different
higher freight prices for manufactured
goods within Texas than they did
nationwide so in other words if you
opened up the factory
in Dallas and you made widgets and then
you shipped it on one of these you know
a railroad line so there were about
three of them owned by by
northeasterners and you shipped it to
Austin the railroads would charge you a
higher price then if Austin imported the
same widget from Connecticut and there
was an economic reason for this because
the railroad magnates had invested in
factories in in what is now the Rust
Belt the industrial belt and so they had
this master plan for what's going to be
made we're in in the United States and
consequently you know Texas was and it
was going to specialize at that time in
cotton and cattle and later in oil and
the manufacturing was going to be done
in Pittsburgh and Detroit and so on and
then they had their grand plan it was
part of this integrated business
operation well Texas businessman did not
like this at least the ones who weren't
specialized in the commodity
agricultural sector and the Texas
Railroad Commission was created in order
to prevent this kind of manipulation of
prices and so and that that so there was
always a challenge from Texas business
this was true in the south in general a
William Gibbs McAdoo who became a
Treasury secretary for President Woodrow
Wilson and was an early progressive was
a southern businessman in Tennessee and
he wanted to open up an electric trolley
car company in an in Nashville and other
Tennessee cities so he went to the New
York bankers to ask them to invest and
they weren't interested they would
invest in a railroad that would go to a
plantation or to a Minehead or to a silo
you know to ship the products out but
they didn't see why Tennesseans needed
trolley cars I mean you know it's not as
though word they were a first world you
know industrial society so consequently
I explained in my book made in Texas
there was an insurgency led against the
conservative oligarchy in Texas and
other southern states which were doing
quite well out of this system and they
were in in an alliance with these
northeastern investors who were doing
quite well of this system too they
wanted to modernize and industrialize
Texas and other southern states and in
this group includes Colonel Edward
Mandell house who was Woodrow Wilson's a
principal advisor who'd been a very
important Texan politician in the late
19th and early
century it really flourished under a
congressman Lyndon Johnson Maury
maverick the mayor of San Antonio and
when he went as a US Representative to
Washington Sam Rayburn these New Deal
Texans you know we think of the New Deal
and of liberalism nowadays as a matter
of social security and you know writing
checks and income combatant poverty
that's not the way they viewed it I mean
that was part of the program but outside
of the Northeast in the Midwest which
industrialized during and after the
Civil War the main goal of the New Deal
Democrats was to industrialize the rest
of the country too and they did it
through means like the Tennessee Valley
Authority through the Lower Colorado
River Authority the LCRA in Texas which
brought electricity to rural areas that
would not be supplied by the free market
alone by the interstate highway system
you know basic infrastructure the
old-fashioned oligarchy in Texas and
other southern states they had the
infrastructure they needed you know
which was you know the railroad or the
canal coming up to where they got rid of
their agricultural products but so the
new dealers created a new industrial
electrical modern 20th century
infrastructure so you could have small
businesses you could have manufacturing
and that's why I call them modernists
rather than liberals because some of
them were not liberal so you know some
of them were segregationist some of them
were very conservative socially but they
wanted a high-tech modern Texas and in
my view their successors in recent times
have been figures like Ross Perot and
Admiral Bobby Ray Inman the former head
of the National Security Agency in
Washington who played a key role in
bringing university private of inter
capital and government resources
together to help create the Silicon
Hills in Austin and the silicon Prairie
as it's called in Plano so the solution
for these modernists for how you bring
Texas out of being a backward sort of
third world Banana Republic into a
modern society given the fact that many
of the local elites that have the money
aren't interested in doing so and and
the private investment in New York and
other cities is not interested in doing
so their solution was to use the federal
government as a venture capitalist
not to create enterprises directly but
to build the infrastructure that would
then attract opportunistic capital and
and so that modernist tradition is
symbolized by the state capitalist or
federal government venture capitalist
tradition it's symbolized by the LCRA
by NASA which Johnson was instrumental
in creating as well as in having a lot
of the jobs put in Texas by the internet
which was originally a Pentagon program
linking researchers at various
universities it was originally called
DARPA net after the Defense Advanced
Research Projects Agency which is the
high tech or indie wing of the Pentagon
well that brings us up to the present
there these two traditions then there's
the old what I call the traditionalists
which tends to be right over all
especially with the commodity sector
with cattle cotton in oil which is very
similar in some ways and then there's
this high-tech modernist sector where
you see government and business working
together rather than as enemies in order
to promote a first Industrial Age and
then an Information Age society the
modernists peaked between the 1930s in
the 1960s what we've seen since then is
the revival of the traditionalists now
within the republican party the texas
has become a two-party state of course
but what has happened both in texas in
the nation as a whole is that the
conservative wing of the Democratic
Party which was democratic only because
of the outcome of the civil war vote the
way you shot you know as I was told
growing up these conservative Democrats
gradually defected from the Democratic
Party the Republican Party to the point
by the 1990s they'd taken over and this
was a much longer process than people
give it credit for it didn't all start
with the civil rights revolution it goes
back to Franklin Roosevelt in his young
Ally Lyndon Johnson and others tried to
purge the Conservatives from the
Southern Democrats in the 1936 and in
1938 the congressional elections as a
result there was a movement to deny the
nominate reen AMA nation to franklin
roosevelt in 1940 by democratic
conservatives who wanted a
Cactus Jack garner FDR's first
vice-president to be President instead
there was a rebellion against Roosevelt
1944 in which of the Texas Democratic
Party just split in half between the
loyalists that is loyal to FDR led by
LBJ and by the Texas regulars who were
anti Roosevelt Democrats in 1948 of
course Strom Thurmond walks out of the
Democratic National Convention over the
civil rights issue you know and should
have been President according to senator
Trent Lott instead of that in the
various subversive left-wing or harry
truman then of course 1964 Lyndon
Johnson signed the Civil Rights Act and
turns to Bill Moyers his aide and says
there goes the South for a generation
showing what an astute political
prognosticator he was as well as a
politician the process was more or less
complete by 1994 when following the
Republican capture of both the House and
the Senate 400 sitting state officials
in southern states converted within a
few weeks from the Democratic Party to
the Republican Party they'd run as
Democrats but after Gingrich led the
Republicans to victory in both houses
they just switched and and that
essentially brings us to the present
situation in which I argue the book is
not entirely about george w bush or even
primarily he doesn't even show up until
the chapter 4 really but i do argue that
george w bush represents the
consummation of this 50 year process of
southern conservatives leaving the
democratic party and joining the
republican party even though he was born
in connecticut i think he's a genuine
cultural and political texan of this old
Texan traditionalist school which as i
say historically was democratic rather
than republican his father was an
interesting transitional figure you know
the yankee country-club republican you
know who sort of trying to turn into a
pork rind you know populist and he could
never quite pull this off in a way
that's totally convincing I find myself
convinced by george w bush i mean he
grew up in West Texas and one of the
most conservative areas of Texas I from
the time he was an infant and as I think
you're influenced more by your neighbors
in you know the neighborhood kids and
the people you grow up in
I I don't think as many of my colleagues
in journalism and politics on the East
Coast think that this is all some kind
of act that he's really a liberal
Rockefeller Republican who just sort of
pretends in pub I don't believe this for
a moment
and one reason I don't believe this is
because of you know his actual policies
you know if he wants to be reelected in
2004 he would have from the day he got
inaugurated tried to reach out to Goran
Nader voters he cannot get reelected
without having people who voted for Gore
and have voted for Ralph Nader vote for
him in the next election that's just
mathematical certainty he has not been
governing that way
he seems but most of his policy
initiatives both domestically and in
terms of foreign policy are directed
towards his conservative southern base
for example his decision on human stem
cell cloning there's a consensus in
Congress to ban human cloning
that is a cloning of cells that would
result in babies being brought to term
there's no consensus about banning
cloning you know of say skin cells which
would be allowed to grow you know to
multiply until they're 14 cells and then
you extract some of these stem cells and
maybe grow skin grafts you know maybe
you could grow new organs or something
like that it's purely pressure from the
southern Protestant right which has led
Bush to shut down federal funding for
this with the consequence that we now
have scientists actually leaving the
country not just research but scientists
moving to Singapore to Britain to Europe
where they don't have a leis a fair
regime all of those countries ban human
cloning but they permit some moderate
experiments with this and it's it
because of the southern religious right
you know this is becoming more and more
difficult in the United States and the
gravity of this can't be exaggerated
agriculture pharmaceuticals even surgery
may be transformed by genetic
engineering and by the cloning of cells
in the course of this century and there
really is a danger of the US will fall
behind Europe and Asia in this respect
and foreign policy we saw today I saw in
the newspaper the
the us having lost the support of much
of the British population along with the
leaders of Russia Germany China and
France
says it can count on the support and
invasion of Iraq of Australia and
Bulgaria well the the the premise of US
foreign policy since Franklin Roosevelt
it's been bipartisan it was shared by
Ronald Reagan by this president's father
was that the way to keep the peace in
the world is to keep most of the other
great powers on our side and we were so
successful in this that we brought the
Soviet Union to its knees in the 1980s
because the soviet union's did not have
a single great power Ally we did not win
the Cold War the United States did not
win the Cold War the United States went
as part of an allied coalition where we
added the significant military resources
of Western Europe of Japan and by the
80s the Communist People's Republic of
China
that's what's bankrupted the Soviet
Union if we had tried to bankrupt them
on our own you know I don't think the
American voters would have stood for the
amount of military spending that would
have been necessary so when we can be
part of a coalition that multiplies our
military power we're much better off in
his unilateralism in this contempt for
alliances in the fact that he has broken
more treaties he's just you know
laterally abrogated more treaties than
any president US history clearly this is
an ideologue ideology at work I mean
this is this is a drastic departure from
the practice of his father and of
previous Republican presidents as well
now does it have a subcultural origin I
think it does if you look at polls of
public opinion and they only go back in
the United States to the early 20th
century it's very interesting you find
that uh white southern Protestants as
long as the polls have been taken now
for 50 or 60 years are more likely than
the rest of the population to favor
military intervention abroad but they're
also more hostile to having alliances or
international organizations at eye
America's hand one historian in my quote
Joseph Frey says quote while adopting
the stance of cold warriors during the
Cold War the vast majority of
southerners cast aside any pretense of
internationalism
the South quickly became disillusioned
with United stations after 1945 in
persistently favored unilateral actions
when US interests were in question one
journalist points out that the greatest
support for Bush's foreign policy now
that comes from quote a high school
educated white male from the rural or
small town south so I think if you know
southern culture this foreign policy is
a fairly accurate reflection of the
Preferences of many if not all white
Southerners it but it is the first time
we've had a southern conservative
president since before the Civil War
there can southerners who have been
president like Woodrow Wilson Jimmy
Carter Bill Clinton Lyndon Johnson there
been conservatives who were not
southerners like Nixon and Reagan and
Coolidge but we haven't got the full
package of southern conservatism which
is distinct from northeastern and
Midwestern and West Coast conservatism
until now just going over a few other
foreign policy topics in Israel the
greatest support for the Bush
administration's policy of aligning US
interests with the ariel sharon's regime
and essentially you know talking about a
palestinian state making it clear that
one will be physically impossible as a
result of Sharon's actions for you know
five 10 15 years
that pressure is not coming from Jewish
Americans most of whom voted for Al Gore
and remain Democrats it's coming from
the Christian Zionists of the Protestant
religious right who believe according to
their interpretation of the book of
Revelation and other prophecies that the
Jews have to not only be returned to
Israel but have to acquire historic
Judea and Samaria if necessary by ethnic
cleansing of Arabs before the Battle of
Armageddon can take place in the end of
the world can come in Christ can return
I mean this this is expounded at great
length every Sunday and many pulpits
mostly but not exclusively in the south
and but that's where the political
pressure for know for the Bush
administration to break with the
somewhat even-handed approach to the
arab-israeli conflict is coming from
within the Republican Party
finally al Qaeda
now to me the most disturbing thing
about bushes ties to the religious right
which put him in the White House because
it was a religious Rite operatives who
masterminded the campaign against John
McCain which which won the Republican
nomination for George W Bush is the
response of his religious right allies
to September 11th on September 13th 2001
on Pat Robertson's television show the
700 club a Jerry Falwell attributed the
terrorist attacks to God he said quote
God continues to lift the curtain allow
the enemies of America to give us
probably what we deserve unquote as of
Robertson the founder of the Christian
Coalition expressed his agreement
Falwell blamed the attack on federal
judges end quote the pagans and the
abortionists and the feminists and the
gays and the lesbians the ACLU people
for the American Way I point the finger
in their face and say you helped this
happened as I write my book the suicidal
terrorists who flew hijacked planes into
the World Trade Center the Pentagon and
the ground in Pennsylvania believed they
were on a mission from God
Jerry Falwell and Pat Robertson agreed
now did our president denounce this as
blasphemy if not treason no there was
sort of a mild reprimand about the
wording from the White House spokesman
and then a George W Bush immediately
went back to business cultivating the
religious right on Friday October 11th
2002 a little more than a year after the
terrorist attacks Joyce Meyer of Joyce
Meyer ministries of fit in Missouri told
The Christian coalition's annual road to
victory conference that the American
people were sinful and had you know got
what was coming to them she said quote
if we don't obey God God's protection is
lifted unquote on the same day President
Bush greeted the delegates with a video
message in which he promised to continue
promoting the agenda of the religious
right now you know I try to be you know
at least somewhat objective and see both
sides to an issue but when any Americans
suggest that the 3,000 people who were
murdered by these maniacal terrorists
were somehow even indirectly promoting
God's act of bringing retribution on the
American people you would think they
would be run out of public life you
would think that a president United
States in one of the two major parties
would
ask them and for their help politically
or in anything else you think they'd
never be spoken to again but the
religious right controls one of the two
major parties and that's essentially the
southern right it's we're not talking
about Catholics we're not talking about
mainline Protestants we're not talking
about Orthodox Christians essentially
these are Southern Baptists Pentecostal
lists Church of Christ and some others
who are part of this evangelical
coalition well what does the future hold
at the moment the southern conservatives
have never been more powerful in
Washington since the 1850s you actually
have to go back to the Buchanan
administration right before Lincoln to
find the House the Senate the Supreme
Court and the White House dominated by
conservative southerners the way it is
now this time in the Republican Party
which Lincoln founded although George W
Bush just recently restored the habit
which his father had ended of sending a
presidential bouquet to the Confederate
Memorial in Arlington I'm not sure what
mr. Lincoln looking down on this thought
about that I think their power has
peaked within Texas and within the
nation as a whole
largely because of demography at Texas
has or will soon have a non-white
majority the electorate is still 75%
white or Anglo but it will take a little
time to catch up but I think Texas will
look more like California in 10 or 20
years that doesn't mean it will be
necessarily liberal because all Latinos
and all african-americans you know are
concerned not necessarily liberal and in
social views or economic views but it
would be quite different I mean it will
cease to be a southern anglo-celtic
Protestant tribal society where Texan
that's what Texas means you know we're
going to become a pluralistic
multiracial multi-religious melting pot
of the kind that the rest of the country
has been for many generations nationally
I think the power of this kind of
conservatism has peaked I think
conservatism in the United States and
probably Texas too as I long in vigorous
future ahead of it you know there are
many different varieties of conservatism
there's libertarian conservatism you
know there's the kind of Reagan Democrat
you know blue-collar populist sort of
conservatism but I
this kind of conservatism associated
with Strom Thurmond and Trent Lott and
Phil Gramm a one of these conservative
Democrats whose which the Republican
Party and I would add George W Bush I
don't think there's much of a future in
it
so and I think that's that's good news i
I think it's done enormous damage
historically to Texas I think it has the
potential to do a great deal of damage
to the United States but I think it's
not going to be around for much longer
and whatever replaces that I think will
probably be better thank you I'll take a
couple of questions and then sign some
books yes just curious about your
opinion of like congressman watts and
Thomas all and Walter Williams
I admit that there's a lot of racism
both among Democrats and Republicans in
the south and it's probably generational
because I see kids that play with each
other and they don't think anything of
color I mean it's it's no big deal
but once the generation passes away I
mean you look at Bush Powell Condoleezza
Rice he has blacks that are prominent in
his administration that must agree with
him to some degree or other well you
notice in my statements and talking
about the contemporary version if this
kind of southern conservatism I didn't
mention race I think this is greatly
exaggerated I think for maybe Trent Lott
generation and so on you know that was
very important what liberals have to
understand is that all people of color
are not necessarily liberal you know you
can have very conservative societies
like many in Latin America where there
is no racial bar whether there's a great
deal of a racial mixing and mestizaje
you know to use the Mexican phrase and
they can still be quite conservative in
social values and in economic values and
so on so I think it's it's the Liberals
have been gambling that the mere growth
of Latino population plus the black
population will automatically produce a
liberal majority I'm not sure that's the
case I think and I think George W Bush
to his credit I think has been trying to
reach out to african-americans and
Latino Americans I'm not sure about all
of his constituents but I don't
that's the way that conservatism will go
in the future and I asked one morning
you talked about stem-cell research
orrin hatch was here a few months ago
and he pointed out that he differed with
the president partly on the mormon
different view of when conception begins
when life begins and also like when I
walk into Whole Foods up here it's like
something out of the 60s I mean
coevolution quarterly Whole Foods I mean
the whole earth people this group of the
the people from the left
mother earth news they're just as
opposed to genetically modified or by
old tech foods as anybody on the right
ever is they're trying to hold back
scientific research just as furiously
whether that's that's absolutely right
there's a coalition among leftists who
were opposed for environmental reasons
to genetic engineering just so called
frankenfoods the leftists are more
worried about plants and animals being
modified not human beings I don't know
what this tells you but they're afraid
they will eat you know some mutant
carrot you know which will yeah not
realizing that all carrots are mutant I
mean they're the products of
old-fashioned genetic engineering
through selection and you're just
speeding it up through the laboratory
jeremy rifkin a sixties left activist
teamed up with william kristol the
editor of The Weekly Standard last
summer and circulated a petition this
was a religious right conservatives
teamed up with environmental leftists
calling on Congress to ban all research
into human stem cell cloning and in
Europe the left is responsible for this
movement against genetic engineering
this is terrible terrible folly
particularly when animals and farm
animals and plants are involved Edward o
Wilson I've discussed this with him it
was a great Darwinian biologist of our
time he's one of the world's leaders in
conservation and he shocks many of the
environmentalists allies by saying that
we need genetic engineering why is that
if you can create genetically engineered
livestock and genetically engineered
crops so that you can use half as much
land to produce twice as much fruit or
protein or whatever you are opening up
much of the Earth's surface for
wilderness you can bring back the
Prairie around here you know where you
have farms in
inches.now you can save the Amazon the
last thing you want to do in the 21st
century with an exploding population is
to use primitive Neolithic methods of
Agriculture
so the peasants have to go burn down you
know part this is why you've had this
smoke coming up from Mexico they're
using these primitive slash-and-burn
agricultural methods you know you burn
down a forest and then you grow some
crops on it and then you leave it for a
few years and burn down another part of
the forest so high-tech agriculture that
minimizes the waste of land and water
and other resources is the best thing
that can ever happen to the environment
and it has been in the past for example
a few people realize the remaining
forests in Britain there aren't a whole
lot of them were saved by James Watt who
invented the steam engine if there had
not been the steam engine in the
Industrial Revolution getting coal as
the basis of energy every tree in
England would have been cut down in the
course of the latter 18th and 19th
century by British peasants burning
firewood you know using a flax fir for
their houses and having that so the best
thing that ever happened to the
environment already in this country we
have more acres in forests now than we
did in 1930 the actual amount of acreage
in farmland peaked in the 1950s and has
been steadily shrinking most of it going
back to wilderness particularly in the
northeastern states a lot of the forests
you see in New England in the 19th
century were farmed they were fields and
it's because of cars 1/4 of all farm
acreage in the United States up until
the early 20th century went to growing
oats for horses and mules I mean the
form of transportation that's gone now
and a lot of these the land area that
was devoted to the use of forage for you
know these animals that pulled us around
has been replaced I mean their problems
obviously with with industrial
civilization and pollution and with oil
and with other sources of energy but but
the great thing about the Industrial
Revolution is it has permitted us by
mining raw materials and energy from
underground
spare much of the Earth's surface from
agriculture yes at the back president
bush reaching out to the African
Americans just because he put
Condoleezza Rice and Colin Powell in his
cabinet he bailed out on the blacks when
he when he came out against the
University of Michigan affirmative
action program and that's what they're
gonna remember come election time
they're not going to think about whether
colon Powell is there who who admitted
he got where he is a lot because of
affirmative action and so did
Condoleezza Rice they're not going to
remember that they're gonna remember he
bail out on them on the University of
Michigan what you may be right about
that I was just saying I don't want to
give the impression that I think all
southern conservatives or all
conservatives in general have personal
racial racist attitudes I don't think
that's the case some do but many do not
that was my only point yes sir real
close attention to issue regardless with
Democratic Republican and I was
wondering like with during the race
Clinton was stepping out and then of
course the bush regime was in as well as
John McCain my question is I personally
like John McCain he's great man I think
great man great honor but he was kind of
really kind of railroaded wouldn't you
say
in this administration I understand he
wasn't even invited to the White House
and as a hero I mean for our country
what's my understanding that Senator
McCain does not think highly of this
president and I assume the feeling is is
reciprocated you're as an independent
you're a member of rapidly-growing group
in the United States there were hardly
any independence back in the 1960s today
it's about a third of the electorate and
according to some polls independents
outnumber self-described Democrats and
Republicans the problem is with our
electoral system most democracies have
something called proportional
representation which permits you to
elect third and fourth parties and you
can debate whether this is good or bad
but the point is in our system which is
shared with Britain and a few other
english-speaking countries it's called
first-past-the-post if you vote for a
third party candidate in a three-way
race it's really kind of self-defeating
you know it's like the nadir people how
- like george w bush when they would
have preferred Al Gore as their second
choice candidate there's a method called
Instant Runoff voting where you would
rank the candidates and if your first
choice candidate doesn't win your second
choice your vocalist your second choice
that would prevent that kind of outcome
it was recently adopted by the citizens
of San Francisco for all of their city
officials but it will take a long a long
time for us to reform the electoral laws
and until then my advice is to work
within one of the two parties
particularly in a close race because if
you cast your vote for third party in a
close race it may have perverse results
yeah another follow-up question to is
why can't people see when reading a
paper how far we're going backwards
every day and just little laws they're
mean
I mean it's overwhelming I thought well
I'll start clipping newspaper articles
about bills were being signed and
reversed with its environment whatever
with this administration and pretty soon
I got a you know a stack five feet long
and it almost looks like you're neurotic
because you're starting to clip out it's
just awesome to be like you've got the
basis of your own candidacy yes sir I
don't think anybody's asked a question
about Iraq yet it looks like as we've
been told very recently there there's
there's no secret player the president
in this administration does make the
decisions he he calls the plays and he
seems to want to go in and have a war
with Iraq and he seems to want to have
it now not not six month you know and
there's a time problem because of the
Iraqi desert of putting troops in there
and so forth so if you're gonna do it
this year you probably didn't have to do
it soon could you with could you tie
that into all of this is that simply
that the southern Celtic male coming
forward here for the conquest let's go
why why does he stay in sort of alone I
mean well he has support from many
southern voters more so than in the rest
of the country
however the strategists behind the
strategy are not themselves southern
people like Paul Wolfowitz the number
two at the Pentagon this is really his
strategy in the first Bush
administration Wolfowitz drafted when he
worked for Dick Cheney who was then the
Secretary of Defense
what recalled the defense policy
planning guidelines and this was a
vision of us grant strategy after the
Cold War and it was you know a plausible
theory I disagree with it but the
argument was that the US should maintain
unassailable military power so that
other great powers including the nations
of Europe in of East Asia and they had
Germany in France and Japan in mind as
well as China and Russia would see that
you know resistance as futile as they
say in science fiction and so you know
everybody else you should dismantle your
militaries and trade with each other so
essentially the vision was that the
position of West Germany and Japan visa
vie the US during the Cold War where the
u.s. assumed responsibility for their
military protection in their regions in
return they concentrated on exporting
Toyota's and Volkswagens you know
instead of Ponder's and ver mocks and
zeroes in the you know so this was a
theory about how to assure lasting world
peace
it requires taxing the American people
you know to have the combined military
of the entire planet for the next
century I'm not sure they were thinking
about the political aspects of this but
nevertheless it was a serious theory
this was leaked to the press the first
president Bush George Herbert Walker
Bush thought this was insanity and as
did Secretary of State James Baker and
others and they quickly put the kibosh
on this this was never adopted as
official US policy Baker Eagleburger
others went out in public and gave
interviews and said oh no you know this
was just blue skying
nobody takes this seriously so that was
rejected another one of Wolfowitz his
ideas that was shared by Cheney was go
all the way to Baghdad and this was
defeated by George Herbert Walker Bush
by colon Powell then chairman of the
Joint Chiefs of Staff so what we saw in
the second Bush administration is that
the people who lost the argument
within the first Bush administration
Wolfowitz and Cheney and Rumsfeld who's
part of this circle they managed to
persuade the son to accept two policies
that his father had had more or less
publicly rejected one is going on to
Baghdad in deposing Saddam Hussein the
other is this a unilateral doctrine
where the US will
less monopolized world military power
for the foreseeable future and use it
for pre-emptive warfare against a
speculative threats now as I say none of
this was invented you know in in the
south or in Texas I mean it was invented
on the banks of the Potomac in the
Pentagon about ten years ago mostly by
Northeastern academics like a Paul
Wolfowitz who was a professor before he
went into government but the strongest
support is found in the south because of
this combination of military values in
this traditional suspicions about
entangling alliances and international
organizations yes sir what will be your
concern about this book which is
excellent exposition but in my opinion I
think this this planet the whole planet
Earth is controlled by about 500 people
and the globalization the control of
power is the whole human beings we are
in dangers very in a great danger
because you you see the the protests
against who are all over this country
all over the world because is here the
the the right-wing the extreme is the
the people who want war they don't want
peace in this planet they want
destruction for the whole human beings
because I think was the right winners
and the racist they they don't care
about peace for the whole planet and
then my final statement is can we live
together can we share this planet if we
weekend or we live together or we die
together thank you well thank you I
think as critical as I am of the
conservatives I don't think that they
want mass extinction and and in terms of
a small number of people controlling the
world I think I think it's more
pluralistic than that you know there are
there many elites within this country
and other countries acting to check and
balance each other in terms of living to
there that's the great challenge
particularly with new technologies what
is happening now and is what people call
the age of super terrorism individuals
just as you as an individual have you
know the power that IBM did not have 40
years ago you know with your PC you have
this incredible power your car has all
of these micro processors in it it's got
more brain power you know then the US
military did in in the Vietnam War you
know in terms of computational ability
but but this can be used as we've seen
for evil as as well as good and up until
now historically the only organizations
that could kill vast numbers of people
were States you know the Roman Empire
you know the Chinese Empire the Ottoman
Empire now you're you have a technology
where a single individual and we're
really focused on these al-qaeda type
terrorists who are dangerous enough but
the real danger or the greater danger
may come from people in the advanced
nations like the United States Europe
and Russia like this anthrax terrorist
who is likely to be somebody actually
from the federal military-industrial
complex who had access to these
high-tech weapons and you know we don't
know what's going to happen there the
Conservatives and the Liberals both have
different answers I think they're
they're both inadequate the conservative
answer is well we'll go out and hunt
them down and smash them you know and
then we'll have peace you know and so we
did this in Afghanistan and it was
necessary and you know that was part of
the campaign but turns out when you
smash them in Afghanistan they start
popping up in Bali Indonesia you know in
Paris France in Rome Italy and you know
here again at some point so it's not a
simple matter of sending out the posse
and finishing them off once and for all
I think the liberal answer in some ways
is a bit more superficial because the
Liberals say well violence and hatred
are caused by poverty so if we we you
know bring the rest of the world up to
American Northern European living
standards at that point people will be
peaceful and free well that just goes
against all of history history shows
that as Aristotle said no tyrant ever
conquered a city because he was cold and
hungry
it's rich people who dream of world
domination I mean if you're a peasant
you know and you're worried that your
cow will die tomorrow you're not
planning to conquer a continent the
struggle in the 20th century was between
the three richest nations of the world
for world domination the British Empire
Germany in the United States it wasn't
you know Honduras you know challenging
Germany and Britain in the u.s. for
world domination so and if you look at
al-qaeda these are not poor people Osama
bin Laden is a prince of the Saudi royal
family
most of these terrorists came from the
very top of the class structure in
countries like Egypt in Saudi Arabia
they were the college educated elite
they were the upper-middle class they
were the professionals these were not
the poor peasants who for obvious
reasons don't organize transnational
business like terrorist networks using
the latest in advanced technology so I
think the Liberals really have to think
twice before they think that merely
giving people more wealth and power it's
not going to release you know the Hitler
is in the osama's who couldn't do
anything when they were poor but now
that they have you know it advanced
economies and advanced weapons can do
something about it well if this
conservative solution of hunting them
down and whacking them doesn't
necessarily work and the liberal
solution of making everybody rich and
powerful doesn't necessarily work well
what does I suspect and I'm in a
pessimistic mind already here that we're
gonna have to change the way we live in
the course of this century I think we're
going to have to accept national
identity cards more intrusive federal
searches I think that you already see
this after September 11th businesses are
going to think twice about putting all
of their employees and their operations
in a single building somewhere I think
we may in much of the industrialized
world return to kind of a quasi medieval
landscape where you have sort of
fortified decentralized structures you
know with electronic and video
surveillance and people shift around
uncomfortably when you say this because
it means you know one of things
President Bush's says these terrorists
will not make us change the way we live
well I think they probably will
I think after after enough terrorism
including terrorism from within you know
from Americans like Timothy McVeigh this
anthrax terrorist if he's an American
I think you know we're going to change
the way we live and accept a degree of
regimentation which those of us who grew
up in in the older world will find you
know quite quite unpleasant but I think
that maybe it's not a solution but it's
a way of ameliorating the danger and one
more question switching parties who do
you think in the democratic party might
be enlightened enough to in the White
House in 2004 well if you had to be
enlightened to win the White House well
as I say I'm not going to handicap the
candidates they're a number of strong
candidates out there on the Democratic
side I will say that governors tend to
do better than senators do you know
governor Bush governor Clinton governor
Carter and there's a reason for this
there's there's some reasons if your
senator particularly if you've been
there for 10 or 20 years you know you've
had to vote on every single
controversial issue that ever existed
snail daughter's you know abortion civil
unions taxes and so on and so you have
all of this thrown at your face when you
run for office if you're a governor you
could have kept diplomatic silence about
a lot of these controversial issues the
second advantage that governors have you
can run against Washington you can say
unlike these senators and congressmen up
there including the ones of my own party
creating this mess you know I ran a
state I balanced the budget or whatever
third governor's have the sort of a
president a governor even of a small
state has the largest coalition of
donors and of party activists who can
man phone lines and get out the vote and
all of that Dwarfs the resources that
all but a few senators can can mobilize
so I think we're now at the stage where
the names being touted the most or US
Senators you you have a couple of
governor's coming in now like Graham
from Florida and Howard Dean from
Vermont write a bill Richardson down the
road but I think what you'll see is as
the election approaches
some of the well-known senators will
fade as they tend to do and some of the
governor's will come from behind and the
fact that you don't know that much about
them is actually an advantage you know I
the reason Abraham Lincoln became
president was it was after all of these
dozens of ballots and they eliminated
every well-known Republican because
precisely because they were well-known
like like uh Seward there were people
who hated them whereas hardly anyone had
ever heard of Lincoln and he hadn't been
in politics except you know in Congress
briefly so nobody hated his guts and he
became a president and a great one well
thank you very much I'll be uh signing
books michael lind is a senior fellow at
the New America Foundation an author of
the next american nation up from
conservatism and vietnam his latest made
in texas is published by basic books on
the web at basic books dot-com Alexander